when you think of musical improvisation
the first thing that comes to mind might
be jazz or the Blues but the practice of
improvisation is actually a part of many
musical traditions all across the globe
[Music]
[Music]
as a classically trained musician I've
personally been working on developing my
improvisational skills over the past few
years as you can see from these charts
that detail how I spend my practice
hours today classical musicians are
known for playing music as written in
the score note for know but this wasn't
always the case this may surprise you
but from the Middle Ages to about the
late 1800s or so improvisation was
actually a big part of music performance
and training so why have classical
musicians stopped learning how to
improvise
[Music]
in classical music improvisation dates
back to the Middle Ages soloists would
add spontaneous embellishments over
familiar melodies and the score provided
served as a skeleton of the melody over
which musicians would add their own
variations an example of melodic
variation today might be found at a
sporting event with the national anthem
singers would typically add in
variations and fills while keeping the
melody and lyrics still recognizable
going overboard with embellishments
however is never ideal because it can
easily lead to a distasteful
interpretation classical musicians also
improvise accompaniments to melodies in
fact the first record of improvisation
in western music comes from 9th century
writings that detail how to add
countermelodies to Gregorian chants
later during the Baroque era this type
of improvised accompaniment became what
is called Basso continuo they use the
kind of music notation called figured
bass which provides a bass line along
with symbols that indicate what
intervals to use chord suggestions and
types of voicings so a musician say a
keyboardist would take this information
and would improvise with and over the
bass line probably the most widely known
example of improvisation in classical
music is the cadenza if you're playing a
Mozart concerto back in the day towards
the end there's always a point where the
harmony reaches a peak and then everyone
stops the pianist or whatever
instruments instrumentalists will do a
solo basically on the themes from the
main parts and traditionally that was
all improvised
yeah that was your thing maybe you would
sew weren't she major that's the
orchestra the connector goes okay
[Music]
okay question is this improvised right
here yeah yeah right and then you go but
maybe you'll try to make it more super
wise
[Applause]
I don't know maybe maybe you do
[Music]
no no right every time you play
something really cool you just be like I
don't know killing a few solos carry on
the tradition of improvising their own
cadenzas including pianist Gabriella
Montero and Robert leaven leavens tells
us something spontaneous sounds
different from something that is not and
the audience benefits from that in a
performance
whenever I've played improvised cadenzas
the audience gets very quiet for the
first time in most of their lives
they're at a classical concert where
they don't know what's going to happen
next I feel like as a classical musician
I should be able to say yeah I can
improvise cadenza you say is the lost
art because they used to do it all the
time they used to but then now people
just play cadenzas that are already
already written out I got the beam y'all
okay Barney themes oh geez the Bonnie
theme song no no
you
[Music]
and then the orchestra my goal
[Music]
[Music]
why do you think improvisation
disappeared from classical when like
they was the nicest edit in the unit
maybe this is partially the reason why
because all these composers wrote their
own versions of cadenzas they would
write it out and I think back in the day
it was to facilitate and help performers
that were just lesser improvisers so
they wanted you know they wanted the
cadenza to be good so they wrote one out
or several out and then because they
exist performers would just latch on to
that and just learn that also during the
19th century the Industrial Revolution
created the middle class and now more
people with disposable income were
interested in music performance and
education rather than hiring
professional musicians middle-class
households can now purchase their own
instruments and perform themselves also
the growth of published sheet music gave
more people access to classical music
the priorities of a lot of classical
music performances recordings concerts I
think it relies on a certain kind of
rigid exactness that's intimidating and
I think he was it wasn't always like
that when you're playing a piece of
Baroque music even the trills which are
meant to be very spontaneous everyone
plays it like that so everyone will then
but where it is back in the day I feel
like they would maybe though
or the 20th century also brought about
breakthroughs in recording technology
now musical performances could be
captured and replayed forever and this
new reality led to the pursuit of
perfection which inevitably involves
less spontaneity and less risk-taking
recordings of famous works by composers
such as Mozart and Beethoven became
canonized as museum music with less
demand for improvised performances or as
Professor Robin Moore puts it
spontaneous innovations cannot occur in
music which is intended to be more a
replication from 1790 than a musical
event of today personally I feel that
improvisation has been making a sort of
comeback in to the classical music role
thanks to many modern composers and this
has certainly been influencing me as
well as looking towards other genres
like jazz flamenco and folk music that
still embrace many forms of
improvisation
I think improvisation is a very valuable
practice very relevant to music making
to listening and to experience music in
a very spontaneous and creative way for
me it's been very fulfilling to learn
how to improvise in these different
styles try improvising with the band do
it improvisation experiments with
irregular pulses and things like that so
I really do hope to see more of an
emphasis put on improvisation as a
practice in both formal and informal
music education moving forward
[Music]
if I were to give myself advice I would
say before you do anything else find
friends to explore this with and friends
that can help guide you and jam with you
because I spent so much time just on my
own at the piano trying to understand
certain concepts about jamming in
general but as soon as I started to play
with other people
our jam with Adam want being one of them
opened up a different perspective a
different kind of understanding about
all of this I have my formula of
improvisation there is inspiration
there's imitation and then there's
recreation the inspiration is what we
are inspired by it's the template what
it's what catches our attention it's
what gives us that creative feeling as
my second step is imitation learning
exactly what that template is learning
how to play that template backwards
forward learning it like the back of
your hand okay this is where the skill
portion comes in the recreation the most
important step recreating adding your
flavor to it but those are the that's
like the formula for a formula that I
use for improvisation all the time
[Music]
thank you so much for watching and if
you'd like to see more videos don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]
[Music]